the goal of both the juice Mission and
eventually the Europa Clipper mission is
to assess the habitability of these
worlds and Juice specifically will fly
by Europa it'll fly by Callisto but then
it will go into orbit around Ganymede
and Ganymede is the largest moon in our
solar system how long does it take to
get there when we're going to have our
first data so data from juice and the
Europa Clipper Mission will come back in
about the 20 30 31 time frame is when
we'll enter the Jovian system and so the
early 2030s we'll start getting pictures
back don't you think at that point
people are going to be like oh this is
so eight years ago
Jupiter blah blah blah so Paul though
there's a rule an Unwritten rule never
engage in an experiment if you don't
live long enough to see the results okay
oh thanks